welcome to this video plane called
carrot our King and game-playing black
and his play the Kings gambit let's see
how maybe I should let's let's just play
g54 for fun but some always interesting
line okay d for eid for some a gambit
line chief rival just sacrifice a piece
okay okay it's just I just going for
this old order set up the hansteen
variation i think it is called and it's
for a long time known to be good for
black but it's notoriously tricky
typical Kings can better fashion okay
nice g7 Margie is heaven long one I def
61 of Knight f6 is much more natural and
I don't know maybe I can just take you
for yeah I wonder can I why why can I
not take you form yeah I don't know
probably I can't take it it's not so
much the porn it's the the enormous
night here you can play Bishop d3 a
tacit or this move but I just castle
okay here i cannot castle obviously
because the grants runs into this
discovered check but still I came so I
wants to take here and take with the
rook at the end
mm-hmm
hmm
yeah king of a time considering King had
made if he takes twice on before then
Bishop f5 now but probably this is still
on cause for concern
looking position I mean okay let's do
that mm okay maybe grabbing was too
optimistic this is this is certainly
some compensation for white you know
Bishop f4 also also what's interesting
okay if I take efore that's 96
yeah but still that many many pieces
hanging okay if I be taking on fyf are I
know looks tricky this is designed to
expose one more piece of this so Bishop
takes I take at four so that the bishop
is hanging Andrew care for has answered
back 25 and 195 Bishop before just wins
the rook very tricky game we can play 96
now takes rook takes I take on c4 but
then I i only see really a check on f3
Adam don't see have a winner yeah now I
can take a form i can take here hook
takes but he always has g for later so I
I'll take him k need to get through
create in quickly therefore porn I
probably will get lost rupee 8 tween f3
yeah maybe rookie 7f seven or something
their file will will get opened leading
to problems h5 maybe h5 Bishop takes I
have Queen g-form always got a double
check I forgot about that that will
check King g8 our king g eight Bishop d5
checking age 7 23 check now it doesn't
seem to lose but it's very close
ok is going for for an endgame he's got
many pawns this is so not bad at all and
I have a poor coordination
we should be fine not not good at all he
has got the check also bad what is this
three pawns I've got three pawns he's
got six points he's got three parts for
the exchange Wow yeah even players with
her Kings gambit technique usually not
to greater the probability honest too
many fonts minute ok but no use in
resigning
check check check yeah it's still a win
very difficult to do anything he just
needs to push pawns
yes he's high morning yeah plan he wears
on he will manage that yeah it's always
feels a bit like being a fool losing
against this opening it's a entirely
incorrect but not the Kings gambit in
general but this line is entirely
incorrect but yeah midst it's tricky
it's tricky so I guess maybe this was
was too risky after all this was too
risky yeah it's always worth checking
out if you can grab a central pawn
simply because it's a central pawn did
it got it got very very difficult at the
compounds two castles and i briefly
considered that but it looks in
completely insane it wants to allow that
move if the white only a slight edge
just looks crazy d5 check yeah okay
Knight takes Queen d5 wants to take care
take here and claims white is just
slightly better yeah that's crazy I mean
when am I going to play that in a blitz
game yeah this is good for my dear white
is winning actually according to the
computer yeah it's too much on f4 and
the idea is just strong very strong I
simply don't have any coordination I
mean material wise insights bad already
a but not I'm not bad I've got flat
bones but my pieces are simply not not
working well
you can can just play what he did
members perfectly okay yeah this is a
very very easy win because of the
excellent bone structure he's got the
pawns as compensation for the exchange
and it's it's simply a perfect structure
everything's coordinated turn nicely so
I'm at the end it it comes down to
Knight takes e4 which is which is bad it
just gives a wide too much play probably
it's not losing but because of this
crazier castles no I should I should
probably play something else in 96 not
not quite sure what I should play many
opportunities I can I can take I mean
this is not not a bad news probably he
will take with the bishop and now yeah
well my t-72 sir is normal but just
castles yeah well white can always try
to muddy the water slip but essentially
black is the porn up and this is simply
not enough compensation I mean the Kings
gambit player might disagree but it's
just a pawn down I mean if you would
play this a little bit correspondence
game you'd lose every game with white
probably against the decent play button
blitz it's tricky alright thanks for
watching